how competitive are salaries and startup
companies and from my experience it is
often a big misunderstanding that if you
work for a startup you are not getting
paid well but especially for Venture
Capital Bank companies it is often the
goal of these startups to attract top
talent and yes they will absolutely be
willing and able to also pay competitive
salaries for their talent because often
they are well financed they did a big
financing around and these are exactly
the companies you want to look for and
on top of the salary you often also get
compensated with virtual or actual stock
option plans you have this upside that
if the company is doing very well this
might even be a life-changing event for
you so don't underestimate what you can
earn in these environments and follow
for more care advice